Yippee ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here!
Like many fans, I thought Gal Gadot's Wonder
Woman really kicked ass on the big screen
in Batman v Superman.
And with this year marking the 75th anniversary
of the first appearance of Wonder Woman aka
Diana Prince in All Star Comics No. 8, and
with her first live-action solo movie coming
out next year, I wanted to take a look at
5 cool facts you need to know about Gal Gadot's
Wonder Woman!
When creating Wonder Woman's new costume,
the designers wanted to ensure it reflected
the fact she's been around for thousands of
years.
Costume designer Michael Wilkinson drew on
gladiator and warrior influences for the breastplate,
split skirt and armor.
Initially, Zack Snyder wanted her costume
to be made from metal, however this was impractical
as Wonder Woman's stunt sequences and choreography
require her to be able to move with ease.
In the end, the costume designers developed
a material that looked metallic but still
allowed for flexibility of movement, and the
breastplate was designed with expansion joints
that allow Gal Gadot to breathe and perform
her stunt moves more easily.
To finish the costume, it was given a distressed
feel with sword cuts and nicks to show "centuries
of wear from battle".
Wonder Woman's eagle motif appears throughout
her costume, weapons and new logo.
You can see the eagle in her breastplate,
but you might not have spotted the eagle symbol
engraved into the upper part of her sword.
There's also an eagle emblem in the centre
of her shield, although in Batman V Superman
it's hardly visible as the shield is very
old and the eagle emblem has been worn down
from use in battle.
Just like Superman's hidden Kryptonian quote
in his suit, Wonder Woman's sword and shield
also contain an encrypted quote by American
author Joseph Campbell.
The quote was translated by a linguist into
a "hybrid extinct language" and is engraved
into the sword's blade and around the rim
of the shield.
The quote is from Campbell's book "Goddesses:
Mystery of the Feminine Divine" and reads
"Life is killing life all the time and so
the goddess kills herself in the sacrifice
of her own animal."
For Wonder Woman's iconic lasso, the designers
used a distressed 20-ft gold braid.
Her belt has a quick-release attachment so
she can access the lasso and it also contains
a fibre optic cable which lights up and serves
as a reference for the VFX team to enhance
the lasso's look.
In previous incarnations of Wonder Woman,
this particular weapon is often called the
Lasso of Truth and anyone caught in it can
be forced to speak truthfully.
Although, we didn't see this capability in
Batman V Superman, but Zack Snyder has confirmed
that the lasso "can do that".
Although Gal Gadot already had some combat
training having served in the Israeli army,
she still had to undertake a demanding training
program to transform herself into the iconic
superheroine.
She worked with fitness trainer Mark Twight
for over 7 months and trained in sword and
shield play, as well as a range of marital
arts such as kung fu, kickboxing, capoeira
and jiu jitsu.
According to Gadot as she progressed through
the training she noticed how she "started
to stand […] and sit differently" and how
satisfying it was to "transform into something
new."
So guys, what did you think of Gal Gadot as
Wonder Woman in Batman V Superman?
And what are you most looking forward to seeing
in her solo movie?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below!
If you enjoyed this video, do please like,
share and subscribe, and also check out my
DC Movies playlist with videos including 10
amazing deleted scenes from Batman V Superman
and WTF facts about Suicide Squad.
You can check out any of those in the links
below.
Thanks for watching!
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!